the westman islands off the coast of
iceland
cold distant and rugged
this is a tough place for humans
but we're not here to see people
we've come all this way to meet a pair
of beluga whales
you can see glimpses of them from the
boat
but up close and we get personal
little white and little grey once held
in captivity in a chinese aquarium
now about to face a very big change
hi grey the idea is to give them a
better life
and also to learn how whales adapt when
they're taken
out of an aquarium and returned to open
water
we have a great opportunity to learn how
these belugas which have lived in a
captive environment for most of their
lives how they adapt to a more natural
habitat so
what patterns do they develop how do
they adjust to the habitat they're in
and then
we can share that information to improve
the welfare of more than 300 belugas
that are in captivity around the world
the pair spent a decade in this aquarium
in china
performing for crowds but then came new
owners who didn't think wales
should be treated like this
the process of moving them to iceland
took years of planning moving whales
around the world
is as difficult as it sounds
these pools were built especially for
them
these worlds have spent almost their
entire lives
in captivity so they never got a chance
to learn from their mother about how to
hunt or fend for themselves the idea of
returning them to the ocean now is a
non-starter they would not be able to
cope so instead they're being
acclimatized here
ahead of a move to that lagoon a much
more natural sort of habitat for them
[Music]
jessica whiten has been preparing the
whales for release
as that day gets nearer so she gets more
nervous
it's like letting your kids drive for
the first time or
you know sending them off to school i'm
terrified i'm
absolutely terrified have i done the
work that i need to do to prepare them
so they're not
they're not scared and that they're
successful
but now that moment has come little gray
and little white have just been released
into the lagoon
for a decade they were made to perform
for our pleasure
now they get to swim free
adam parsons sky news iceland